we got this story steve bannon charged
with money laundering and conspiracy so
as much as there may be some stressors
for the woke left because they might get
cancelled i'm sure they view that stress
as preferable to being targeted by the
doj for
what well you know i'll be careful here
i am uh reluctant to trust the doj or in
this instance new york states it's the
southern district actually not this is
new york says leticia james i don't
trust any of this stuff i don't believe
them sorry been there done that russia
gate ukraine gate get out of here with
all this nonsense now they're criminally
charging bannon
again because he was just charged with
contempt of congress they're they're
going nuclear against the maga
republicans i expect it'll get way worse
yeah i'm curious if you guys think
they'll indict trump before the midterms
hmm before the midterms i don't know
i don't know i think they will indict
trump i don't see what all of this would
be for if they weren't i don't know
about before the midterms maybe i don't
think they'll do it before the midterms
i just feel like it's not going to move
fast enough
but i will say that i think leticia
james is just a very clear example of
judicial activism i think that she very
selectively picks and picks her cases
and
you know has a clear agenda which i
would not want if i were a person from
new york as my attorney general so what
would you call it if at the federal
level at the state level
democrats are taking positions of
authority in prosecutors offices and
pros uh in the da's offices in um
in the federal government in the in the
in attorneys you know they're getting
jobs as attorneys and judges and stuff
like that and then they're using that
power specifically to target their
political rivals lock them up shut them
down take away their rights like what do
you call that what's going on it's like
corruption or something it's crazy just
corruption
corruption's not a strong enough word
i think
what
is
challenging for a lot of people is that
this is part of the strategic
strategic installment of sympathetic
people at certain levels of government
so
if people are interested in influence
elections you could say you should run
for office but you could also say you
should work at the polls you should be
in this county position you should do
whatever and i think that
the placement of prominent democrats in
offices of attorney general was
something that
most people wouldn't think to do because
they think it should be not a
non-partisan position right they don't
think we should put someone who has a
certain political agenda there we should
put someone who's a really good lawyer
really good at the law um i just i just
mean would you call it fascism
no it's not it's not that i mean fascism
is an element in authoritarianism what
we're seeing is that
ideologically driven democrat types
are intentionally infiltrating these
offices like the soros prosecutors to
get their people out of jail and to put
their opponents in jail it is some kind
of subterfuge yeah it's a subvertive
cronyism maybe yeah i mean but it's it's
i don't want to say civil war i know
everybody's getting ready to drink
because it's not quite there but it's
something close to that where a
political faction is weaponizing the
government to shut down their political
opponents and their political opponents
are just sitting there and taking it
well on msnbc the other day a
commentator said the civil war may have
already started that's right well they
didn't really specify exactly what they
meant by that they were commenting on
bite and speech but that's a little
frightening only one side is really
fighting
exactly and that's the funny thing that
fox news and newsmax had this
incredulous attitude like the left is
talking about civil war oh silly it's
like are you watching what they're doing
to your presidents yeah yeah they're
sitting there saying it's happening and
and we're doing it kathy griffin
basically admitting the democrats are
ready to start a war and then the rights
going like oh there's no civil war
and have fun in prison but uh i i guess
the good news is we'll be gulag cell
mates so you know we'll have you we've
been saying that for a while but you
know i kind of take back
my answer on whether or not they're
going to indict trump because i do think
that a mistake that republicans are
making right now before the midterms is
to constantly talk about trump
constantly talk about what the democrats
are doing to trump i'm not saying we
shouldn't talk about that for the reason
that you just said
but that really doesn't resonate with
most people who are watching fox news
and newsmax most people who are not on
twitter they do not feel like we're in a
civil war even if they see things like
this happening to steve bannon or to
trump they're not thinking this is
probably going to happen to me one day
what i think resonates is the radicalism
that is coming from the left coming from
joe biden and their agenda and the right
is doing a really bad job of talking
about joe biden they're focused so much
on trump when honestly a lot of people
don't want to talk about trump they
don't want to hear about trump i think
they also get lost in like the fact that
joe biden seems so sick and ill right
like you don't want to make fun of
someone like they feel sad for them well
it's like they don't want to say
anything that's like
too
gauche like they don't want to say
anything that was like obviously kind of
cruel to make some someone fun of
someone who's like in decline but like
joe biden does not seem well but i think
they're material in their policies
the way that the left focus solely on
trump the person the man the president
like that's what they think they need to
do abide and it makes them uncomfortable
but what actually they should be doing
is examining his cabinet and who else is
in there and what else is going on like
we are focused on the biden
administration and making joe biden the
face of that that we forget that there
are other people and i think when uh
corinne john pierre came into office
like we're all sort of like wait what
this is your your pick like trampozaki
was like you know pretty good like she
was good she was good and this is who
they followed up with so you should have
questions about every other staffing
decision in the world i kind of feel
like jean-pierre doesn't actually do
work like before the press briefings
she's like watching reruns of friends or
like the office
and then it's like oh i got to do a
press conference and then she goes out
there i remember there was at one point
peter ducey asked her a question and she
goes i don't know that i remember that
happening and it's like that was like
does that mean that they are not telling
their own white house press secretary
what's going on so that they can be like
just deny it like you don't know but
what do you think that seems like a
crazy
girl it's in look i'm sorry it's insane
to care about a white house press
secretary even as jen sackey or kaylee
mcinerney or otherwise because you can't
expect the press secretary to know
everything and to be completely honest i
don't care what party they're with
there's like there's no way no they're
that's their job their job is not to be
honest no it's not exactly it's it's so
it's why is anyone bothering so
everyone's like oh peter deucer peter
ducey asked that tough question and what
he might as well have asked a brick wall
come on what's the point but i stand by
like what's going on with your bindings
cabinet why don't we talk about them
more i feel like i hear nothing about it
well the right does but again i think
that there are i don't think they talk
about enough squishy well i mean i think
that we talk about what we might get
kicked off twitter if we say like the
hhs secretary is not the woman that he
says that he is and i mean there are
different things that i think the right
says maybe not totally effectively i
don't know if republicans in office do
though they don't seem to be i kind of
feel like if if someone was running as a
republican and they just like went up on
the debate stage and were like uh my
principal issue is
no sex change surgeries for children
what say you opponent
and let them be like i'm in favor of
that like okay
can i go home now yeah because regular
people aren't getting that framing
they're hearing healthcare yeah health
care gender reforms trans kids and it's
just like
just you got to keep going be like oh no
i agree with the health care thing for
sure yeah we i i do i definitely think
trans kids are real and they need health
care i just don't think the sex change
surgery is appropriate for minors do you
god i saw a picture of a girl who got a
sex change surgery had her a double
mastectomy she's like 13. the redhead
yeah oh my god her eyes she looked you
got to find this picture too maybe on
the after show we can pull it up yeah
and and the sadness in her eyes after
the mastectomy but so
13 like what are we doing
i mean she looks really young so i want
to i wanna point this out too you know
at risk of pissing off youtube
we just talked the other day about
tick-tockers who are feigning terminal
illnesses for likes we know for a fact
that instagram is making young teenage
girls depressed because they don't get
enough likes do people not think that
they think that those are isolated from
social uh um
what's what is it um social contagion
gender dysphoria what are they called
rapid onset gender dysphoria yeah now
now i we i talked with james lindsay and
billboard chris and i i've said i think
you know trans kids absolutely do exist
i think
endocrine disrupters hormone disruptors
probably play a role in this but i think
a lot of what we're seeing in the news
and with these families
a lot of these kids are undergoing
social pressures from social media to to
to
cave into this and you've got a perfect
storm of
you know a young kid going through
puberty dealing with body changes
popular social media content supporting
transition and parents who also are you
know falling for a salivating medical
industry that can profit predatorily off
of these young children absolutely
disgusting the sackler family if you
look into what it was a dope sick and
they're pushing of uh
oxycodone on the population knowing it
was addictive and telling everyone it
wasn't getting the fda to sign off
mocking people in rural areas where they
were pushing this drug in their emails
to one another these are the people that
are doing this to the kids it's not the
sacklers i'm not saying but it's people
like that that want profit over
everything else now i'm just pausing
like and looking at the news article we
have pulled up and i'm like how did we
segue from steve bannon being charged
with money laundering to trans kids
that was a fast what were we talking
about i'm trying to think about what the
connector what's the problem well we
talked about the ag and then we like we
talked about uh putting your ideologies
they're weaponizing and then we talked
oh
i got it i got trump indictment they're
talking about that before the midterms
you said that they should be talking
more about the people in their
administration i said well you can't say
that some people in their administration
are not the gender and then we kind of
got on to that they are creating though
if we're gonna stick on the whole trans
kids thing which i would not agree with
tim that there is such thing as a trans
person i i just wouldn't there's people
with gender dysphoria there's people
that are confused there are people that
you know cross dress whatever but anyway
they are creating lifelong slaves to the
medical system because okay you do a
quote unquote gender affirming
hysterectomy where you take out a young
girl's uterus and her ovaries oh well
great now you need to freeze your eggs
now you're going to have to use a
surrogate and have to go through all of
these different fertility treatments in
order to have kids one day if you want
to and so they are lifelong medical
patients and of course the medical
industrial complex likes that it's all
connected thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there